one of the pillars in the game from
really early on was this notion of
owning the battlefield and a lot of that
came from this idea that Lincoln's a
Vietnam vet and he has special training
and skills and tactical knowledge that a
normal mobster wouldn't that really
gives him the edge when he's going up
against waves of mobsters and his
training allows him to overcome those
odds and we really tried to incorporate
that into game play and a number of
different ways one we support stalking
in the game so you know you can go
through and you can stalk you're gonna
means you put yourself in the right
position take down an enemy we support a
wide variety of weapons so everything
from classic machine gun all the way to
Vietnam era weapons our version of some
of the weapons that they were using over
in Vietnam handguns that you might
expect the mobster to use all the way to
a more military feeling stuff we can
also gains the ability to put on a flak
vest he gains grenades and other things
that the mob initially at least doesn't
have access to we have a robust cover
system you know it's a type of world
game but we tried to make sure that
there was cover available everywhere and
take cover behind cars you can take
cover behind me pretty much anything in
the environment that looks like it
should be cover and then the way we can
move through the environment he's a
little bit more nimble than mobsters
he's a little bit more effective at
moving through combat and then finally
he's got not just his arsenal of ranged
weapons but he also has his fists and
his knife and one of my favourite parts
of the game are those the brutal
takedowns that you can do on mobsters
you get them stunned or you catch them
by surprise and many times if you pull
one of those off it will have kind of a
ripple effect and the guys around will
it's done for a moment and that gives
you an opening to take down another vest
so we tried to give player number of
tools to make me feel like he really
does own the battlefield
you